you ever work on a shoot with somebody
who uh has bad breath
tom it's the worst dude when i was
16 years old i was on summer vacation
with my buddy at of cape cod he was one
of these rich
kids who had like a house down at cape
cod and um
we were down there and um we had met two
girls around our age and they came back
to his house and
this woman's name um was beth and she
had really
bad breath and my buddy called her breth
right and so but we were going back to
his house and he was like
uh are you ready with breath i don't
know if i can do it man it's so bad he
goes well you just gotta
you gotta get her to eat something or
something so we walk into the
house and he and his girl go into their
room and we walk into the kitchen
and um i said to her i go i'm gonna eat
a spoonful of peanut butter you want a
spoonful of peanut butter and she was
like
what i said i tried
the only thing i'm like what's gonna
kill this breath for sure
i really tried to get her to eat a spoon
she was like do you just eat
peanut butter i'm like it's good protein
and carbs
i was trying to really talk her into it
but just anything for you
yeah i mean it's also it can be rough
with like your buddies
you ever have like sometimes you're
hanging with a friend and you're like
like there's levels of friendship so
some people you feel like you can say
like you know you're close
you know you can say something to but
yeah i don't know there's friends who
have been like
oh you want you want to try this gum and
they're like no i'm good i'm like it's
[ __ ]
awesome though you want to try it and
they're like
and you're like okay do you have friends
who smoke cigars
yeah cigars cigarettes cigarettes are
[ __ ] like cigars are powerful but
it's like such a distinct thing like
cigarettes can make somebody's breath
smell like they're farting into their
own mouth
like they like they have like it's so it
can be
so pungent and it's mixed with like
whatever they ate
and the coffee and you're like do you
have any idea
what everyone else is experiencing
around you right now
it's so bad and you know what's crazy
you're like you know your mouth is
directly under your nose how do you not
smell yeah
you couldn't be any closer to that
breath
but you couldn't possibly be any closer
but yet you still
don't smell it it's crazy
i i think that one thing that the masks
has done
is it's made people who didn't brush
their teeth
realize oh is this what people are
smelling all of the time
i would hope that it's had that effect i
mean
it made me think about burping a lot
remember the first time you burped in
that mask and you're like oh my god
that's what they smell like it's
like really comfortable for you and
it's pretty raw dude i i
the masks have really
made me like think about how much garlic
i eat how much onion i eat
um making sure that i brush my teeth
after i drink coffee
like because it's it's been there's been
a couple times it's been
pretty rough yeah no
it's um it really highlights what's
going on in your mouth
[Music]
foreign